[Music]
good job
straight from monaco really
wow look at the table it's amazing the
casino royale at its best the chef has
to live up to the styling of the table
yeah we'll
[Music]
sitting at the table tonight for your
first course you've got the kingfish
crudo so i have paid again
[Music]
i'll skip that because i don't eat raw
fish i don't like getting more fish from
traveling so three people
don't want the
raw fish okay that's a good part isn't
it yes
[Applause]
i knew it
i knew it
we got peanut butter beer
i'm excited for that very random
you're gonna be perfect what four of
them said they don't eat raw fish oh so
for starter we're from now moving
forward we're never going to tell the
guests what they're having for dinner i
hate you because i'm doing a wine
pairing it it's better this way than
putting so it's not it's actually it's
not raw
okay it's cured so it's not raw killing
it's cured
it's not raw it's not a raw piece of
fish all right what the
like the first rule is like let's not
talk with the guests about what we're
having for dinner honestly i don't think
asia has anything up here it's raw fish
but it's cured it's fully cooked try it
if you don't like it it's fine i don't
think asha has any clue on what she's
caused in scumbags
it's not a raw piece of fish all right
i'll go and check what's cured so it's
not raw
in scumbags
why don't you go and talk to him about
that
i don't wanna just appease him and get
on top of it cool i think that'll fix it
cool perfect
i hope i never see you again he said
that the fish is
how do you feel about that it's still
nice to be fully cooked okay they don't
eat raw fish i'm so glad i'm not saving
these people all right what do we got
yes so we got a couple alters here yeah
absolutely fine with me what about if
you cook the fish that's what i just
offered the fish it'll be seared can you
cook it well done because it's awesome
i can do whatever you like and i'll have
mine well done as well perfect yeah no
problem thank you
and people gotta love them
scrambled eggs what's wrong with
scrambled eggs i make my own rules
scrambled eggs she tried to ask for what
do you mean they're still not gonna like
it so it doesn't matter ryan is super
sensitive and he is reacting the way
he's reacting because he that's his
defense mechanism
and scrambled eggs don't let them get
your head i'll throw her off the boat
but at the same time god i just want to
send him to finishing school torching
it's fine burn it well done actually oh
i got to keep up with you no you're good
oh oh watch my family
okay stripper moves
i'm gonna have a low calorie beer
[Music]
there's no one like that
let's do some work gangsters
ruining a perfectly good fish you'll be
a sir say they have it okay cool low
calorie beer oh my god hungry i'm gonna
waste all this beautiful table
this crap i'm gonna go start a cabin how
long do you think you'll be
i have no idea
i'm so hungry let's hope it's not much
longer
that's not luxury i'll tell you this
check the um the scupper drains if they
need polishing polish them check that
barbecue as well work on giving that a
scrubby dub dub
how many minutes are you raking
oh i can't give it time i mean for you
it's like whenever you know i can't
really give a time
if i cook it in the oven it's going to
disintegrate if i put it in the pan it's
going to disintegrate i can't cook it
any quicker i feel like cavemen would
have figured out a way to cook fish
faster than ryan i need a heart of sauce
i swear he's just doing it to punish
everyone including me
they're still not going to like it so it
doesn't matter how long does it take to
sh like get out of here
when it's ready i'm ready
so hungry
so
[Music]
you